another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the foundation  scp-963 is not to be used for  recreational or procreational purposes  well um this one leaves a frightening  amount open to interpretation  scp-963 is dr bright's medallion which  houses his consciousness and can pass it  on to others if ever it remains  connected to one body for over 30 days  it leaves a permanent copy inside the  body meaning dr bright could  theoretically make clones of himself  he's generally not allowed to do the  latter under any circumstances but  especially if the plan is to say use the  copy to do menial chores or stand in for  him at more boring meetings while dr  wright plays solitaire in his office and  they definitely wouldn't tolerate dr  bright committing any  um  onanism with his clones  thank you very much